[Music]
hello and welcome back to the end game
class as always my name is caleb denby
and today i am going to be walking you
through
some new updates on the corresponding
squares lecture
that i did a while ago so the
corresponding squares lecture that i did
contained correct information it was all
factual
but i have been reading a pretty
interesting book
called the complete
comprehensive chess endings not complete
comprehensive chess endings
and there is a very interesting chapter
on corresponding squares
written by michael zarin
which is uh opening my eyes a little bit
to some new methods some new ways
of constructing corresponding squares so
the focus of the first lecture was
sort of understanding how corresponding
squares like what they are
how they work right white steps here
black steps here
and that's how it works but what this
chapter focused on
in comprehensive chess endings was
how can you actually generally figure
out
what type of corresponding squares
you're dealing with like what
the structure is how can you just
construct those squares
given a position and so that's what
we're going to look at here today
and it's actually quite beautiful in
most cases
generally while there are a ton of
positions
that can be solved using corresponding
squares most of them
uh really fall into a couple different
basic categories
and we're gonna see how you started a
position
just not knowing anything about it and
the steps you take to figure out
for any position where the corresponding
squares are
how to make the corresponding squares so
let's jump into it here
i have a study up on the screen that can
be solved using corresponding squares
in the study it is white to move and to
actually win
this position is the goal so what do we
have here
well we have a lot of the squares being
blocked right
white can't get through on any of these
squares right they're all blocked off
all of these squares are blocked notably
there
are two holes in this great wall
that could be exploited by white
hole number one is this square on
d6 right white could break through
onto d6 and start targeting the black
pawns
hole number two is quite obviously on f4
where white would have a similar idea to
break through
and start targeting the pawns so
the first step in any uh king and pawn
end game study is to try and figure out
some key squares and now key squares
are what are they're sort of the first
step in the process
to lead us to creating our corresponding
squares
so this is the same as the first lecture
we just need to figure out
what are the key squares first of all
what are key squares
well key squares are any square
that if your king arrives at that square
unimpeded then you win the game they're
sort of your
your goal you get to a key square and
the game's over you know you've won you
have a winning position it's easy to win
so let's try and find some squares like
that in this position
to start off with does anybody in the
chat know
any of the key squares
one minute cliff notes yes so that's
basically the one minute cliff notes
is well we'll get back into it for
for this lecture but yeah
so the key squares and yeah great wolf
said f4 d6 maybe key squares and that's
sort of what it looks like
intuitively right you know these squares
are sort of matching
they both target pawns it turns out
though
d6 is a great key square right
and how you can figure this out is you
imagine your king on d6
it looks intuitively like it might be a
key square to determine if it actually
is
you say to yourself can i put the enemy
king any on any reasonable square
on the board and still be winning and
the answer is yes
right we're attacking this pawn the only
square that black could defend the pawn
from is f7
but if the king's on f7 then we still
win because we can play king d7
so that makes d6 a key square it's a
square if we get our king to it we are
absolutely winning 100 of the time
now is f4 a key square
and it turns out the answer to that is
no
why is the answer no who knows
um
who knows why f4 isn't a great square or
a key square sorry
so yeah if the enemy king was on the
perfectly reasonable square
of h5 and it was white's turn then we
would have no better move
than to move away so we don't win if we
get to f4
because if the enemy king's on h5 then
we have nothing better but retreating
but g5 of course does not have that
problem if we get our king to g5
we win the game okay and now here's
we're gonna
where we're gonna start to defer from
the previous lecture
in the previous lecture we started just
trying to create corresponding squares
here
and yeah that's a that's a perfectly
legitimate way of doing it
and in fact i think devoretsky
recommends you do it by
trying to find what's called mind
squares m-i-n-e-d
mind squares they're like land mines if
you step on this square then
you get blown up but there i think is a
better system
described in comprehensive chess endings
and that system
is to first determine the shortest path
between these two squares for both sides
and so i'll give you white's shortest
path and then i'll ask you guys
to give me blacks so the shortest path
between these two squares for the kings
is well we can't step here or here but
we can step here
and then we can go directly between the
two
right so we have here i'll use a
different color other than blue
we have this shortest path right that's
four squares long so using this idea
can you guys tell me black's shortest
path
and all of the squares that we should
include on that path
great wolf asks f6 is a key square too
isn't it
so yes we would always win by getting to
f6 thank you for
for mentioning this by the way but we
don't need to count it as a key square
because if we got to f6 then we would
have had to pass through the key square
g5 first
or the key square d6 first so it's not
very relevant to us because we can't get
there
unless we were previously on a square
that we already knew to be key
why is g5 a key square and not g4 you
make a good point
g4 would also be a key square in fact g4
is maybe
a better way of putting it as as a key
square
but we'll highlight both of them for our
purposes it doesn't really matter
because the only square to get to get to
either of these squares is still uh
well colors are hard is still f4
we'll highlight both
so yeah there are some ideas here
and yeah it's a little bit confusing to
actually try to read in the chat
okay so everybody agrees g6 is one of
the squares for black let's go red again
um
and actually h5 is a square that i don't
think anybody has mentioned right
you need to be able to step to h5 to
counteract
the white king stepping to h to f4 right
otherwise y gets to g4 and so yeah thank
you the person in chat
corrected me g4 is an important key
square
because black must step to h5 when white
steps to f4
in order to control g4 good point
okay other than that we can intuitively
find the square g6
and then the square f7 and then the
square
e7 right and once again we have a path
that is four steps long
okay and let me double check myself here
because this does get rather confusing
four steps long everybody agrees let me
get rid of these silly arrows oh god
it's all falling apart
i should have practiced more with the
arrow colors it's too tough
too tough so we have now the key squares
outlined and the shortest paths
and i'm now actually going to get rid of
the key squares because what
really matters is this path we just
found this path
by use of highlighting those those key
squares
and now notably the square g5 is not
actually on black's shortest path
the reason for that is it takes
uh one two three four
four steps to get there from h5 whereas
it only takes three steps to get to
e7 if we go directly through g6 so g5
doesn't quite count
so what do we have here we have the
shortest path
great job done mission accomplished next
study of course not quite
so how does this tell us what
the corresponding squares are going to
be well actually it turns out
as the title states it's a beautiful bit
of geometry
to be found in these chess end games
and so you can pretty much always
determine
what sort of system for the
corresponding squares
is going to be used by the shape of this
shortest
path in this case the first shape we're
going to look at
is the shape that we see in this puzzle
and that shape is
triangles we see right here
on d4 and e3
these squares are connected by the
square d3
and they form a little mini triangle
everybody sees this
and the corresponding squares g6
f7 are connected by g7
and once again we have our little mini
triangle
right everybody loves triangles and it
turns out
this is sort of the strictest
pattern so what does that mean that
means this is the one we should look for
first because it affords both sides
the least options uh to go wrong
and the reason for that will be known a
little bit later
but that's the reason why we don't
actually choose
this triangle to make our corresponding
squares
because if we did choose this triangle
then black squares
would actually be adjacent to each other
and that allows black a little bit more
freedom
how does that allow black more freedom
well white only has the one squared
to choose from to get to both of these
squares in the meanwhile
black would actually have two squares to
choose from that could step to these
squares
and so we don't want to pick this
triangle because it affords black
more options right it's not quite as
clear
what the corresponding squares are
because there's this ambiguity between
e8 and f8 nobody knows uh if both of
these correspond
to c4 or if only one of them does it's
not
quite immediately clear which is why we
pick
this triangle instead in blue because
for both sides there's only the one
square connecting them and that's as
sort of strict as least uh
the least ambiguous you can get so we
pick this one
to get our corresponding squares and
this
is like i said known as the triangle
system and it's actually
more clearly stated as the eight square
triangle system
in comprehensive chess endings how is
the eight square triangle system
well whenever you get this pattern the
corresponding squares
are very predictably created in an eight
square
manner and that's in fact going to be
the case
for all the systems of corresponding
squares we look at here
they're all going to be created in a
very predictable manner
and so if you remember this system where
you take the shortest path
you look for the shapes and from the
shapes you make your corresponding
squares
it's always going to follow the
predictable system that we learn here
today so system number one to look for
is this one the eight square triangle
system it occurs
when two squares on the shortest path
are linked diagonally
and are connected by just one central
square
okay does that make sense before i move
on to show you
the system of the actual corresponding
squares does everybody understand how we
got here
this is the first thing to look for if
both sides
have two corresponding squares linked
diagonally
that are connected by the one square
sort of in between them
creating a triangle that's the pattern
to go for
what happens if that doesn't exist well
we're going to learn the other patterns
next
but does everybody understand this how
we got here
lots of words says barely anything well
i'm trying to be
sort of repetitive and to say in
different ways slightly so that
everybody sort of gets what's happening
okay
everybody gets it wonderful
so then what is this system of
corresponding squares that i keep
talking about
well it turns out they are numbered uh
pretty simply
right we'll call this square one we
could really call it any anything
this square corresponds to this square
so we have square number one
we'll call the other diagonal square
squared number two
and we'll call the square that links
them square number three
so they're linked in this manner one
corresponds to one
two to two three to three and from there
you build out to the surrounding eight
squares
sorry not surrounding eight squares the
surrounding five squares making eight
squares total
okay so you can start here we'll just
call this number four
i'll make it green and i'm actually
going to
get rid of these squares that are on the
shortest path for a moment
so we build out that one is green the
corresponding square
is uh built on these surrounding five
squares
so we'll call this one number four for
black we have of course
predictably number 5 for white on
c3 note that i ran out of colors
so these two squares c3 and e3 are not
identical
they are different but
there's just not that many colors only
chess so the corresponding square is of
course
g8 then we have
c2 for white h8
for black and i'm actually going to make
this red to try and make it a little bit
less confusing that
don't worry i'm just going to make it
red we have d2 and we have h7
and we have e2 and h6 and it turns out
this pattern is always going to be true
when you have this shape
we started with our initial shape and
now we have this pattern
this pattern of corresponding squares
just is it just
always exists and
what do you do if there isn't enough
space
to draw out this circle of eight squares
well then it turns out you can't
actually use this
pattern you should try to make the
pattern somewhere else or try to make a
different pattern
and that's why this system is the first
we should look for
but isn't always the most common or the
most useful because it requires so much
space to actually create because it is
so
strict with the corresponding squares um
so you won't always see this pattern in
fact most of the time you're going to
see the next pattern that we look at
but it's important to start here because
this is the first one you should look
for
if you can make this one you should and
have to make this pattern
now of course this doesn't yet help us
right our king's over here
our king is over here what are we
supposed to do with this with our king
over here
well it turns out that this pattern can
actually be extended
further down the board and you can
extend it
across sort of the entire board as long
as black doesn't have any meaningful
counter play
what does that mean well for example if
our king were over
on what like negative e you know
negative five
then in this position it wouldn't matter
but in some positions like let's say
black could get through
on the f5 square if our king's far
enough away then the black king can sort
of invade
and create threats of his own that's not
the case here because the black has
no method of entry which means we can
extend it
using this pattern uh
horizontally the squares sort of skip
over each other
so d4 actually corresponds to
b4 in this case so now
despite me saying you know none of these
squares are actually related to each
other i just rounded to colors
b4 is in fact directly related to d4
these two are linked uh
in the meantime b3 is linked to d3
these two squares are the same so what
does that mean
well that means d4 we said
is linked to f7 that also means b4
is linked to f7 and same thing with d3
d3 g7
and b3 g7 are also linked
we can also do this with this green
square here
those squares are linked and vertically
it's the same pattern it just extends
out
skipping over a square and so we can
make this pattern here
very very beautiful right and now
going even further the idea still
persists
you just extend out the squares
so we have green going out here
so that means c4 which corresponds with
f8 also corresponds with a4 so a4
f8 c4 f8 it's all the same blue goes to
a3
and so c3 was corresponding
to g8 it also corresponds to a3
this red square also extends out so c2
which is
h8 also corresponds to a2
and so on and so forth right so on and
so forth
uh king b1 would also correspond
to b1 you can extend like this or like
this it doesn't really matter
and so now we can start to solve the
puzzle
from here we extended the pattern out
and from here it should hopefully be
apparent
what the solution is so let me get rid
of some of these confusing arrows they
were just to show you which squares were
linked to each other
and who sees the solution
now that i'm getting rid of the
confusing arrows
who sees the solution
yeah king a2 is the first move why is
that apparent
well we see that c2
corresponds to h8 right and extending
our pattern
we saw that a2 is the same as c2 right
so a2 also corresponds to h8
which means if we step to a2
our opponent is already on h8 so he
cannot step to h8
which means we win the game uh it's the
same idea
as if the kings were on f4 and h5
right if our opponent's king is on h5
and we stepped eight
f4 he has to move away and we win the
game
it's just an extension of that process
okay and we built it from these two
squares on the shortest path you can use
any squares on the shortest path
and create this type of pattern from
them
so now just to demonstrate
i'm going to put my reputation on the
line
and continue from here with the computer
no wait i can't do this ben will get mad
at me
we'll just play it on the board here so
king a2
now we'll just do it on the board we'll
do king a2 right
and now somebody in the chat threw out a
random move okay
i'm going to pretend i read the move
king g8 king g8 right
so how do we step uh how do we know
which square to step to here well
let's think right we had our triangle
like this black's triangle was like this
right it's a little bit harder without
you know all the drawings on the board
but we can still manage right so where
did black step to
black stepped to g8 which corresponds to
this square in our box right
you know d4 is f7 c4 is f8
c3 is g8 so where do we step to now
well we step of course to a3 because we
can extend out our pattern
this far uh okay so let's say now black
steps to
uh g g7 we'll say black steps to g7
where should we step to now well let's
just try to visualize it this time i'm
not going to draw the circles
we have our square here right and
black's square here
black is on the center part of his
square our center part is d3
we can extend it out to b3 so king b3
now let's say king f7 right and okay
so we have uh our
our little square here he has this
little square here
he's on f7 which corresponds to d4
so where can i step to now well turns
out
i can step in a couple different
directions but
uh this is where it gets a little tricky
okay i know it's been so simple so far
but here's where it gets a little tricky
right
from this part of a square black cannot
access
the corner square and our corner square
is c2 so whenever possible
it's true that moves like king b4 would
win the position as well
it would just take longer but whenever
possible
you should always step closer to your
shortest path
and so king c2 is the best way to step
closer to the shortest path
you want to get into that main square of
eights
and from there get to one of those two
key squares
now it's pretty smooth sailing from here
let's say black plays something
ridiculous like king e8
right all of a sudden we're in our
square
and black is not right so all you have
to do now
is envision well which of these squares
that i can get to can my opponent not
get to
turns out he can't get to his center
square anymore
and so from here we can win the game
let's say king f7 now requires a little
bit of nuance
he has his square we have our square
f7 is d4 so which square can't he step
to
well he could actually step to this
square if we step to e3
but thankfully we are a bit smarter
than that and we can step to the square
he's currently standing on
which is on the shortest path and now it
is
just the easiest position in the world
to win
why is that well it's because since
we're on the shortest path
if you remember which looks like this
black now has to make a decision he
either steps to the left on the shortest
path
or he steps to the right on the shortest
path and we can go
whichever direction black doesn't go so
king e7 would mean king e3
and we win or king g7 or g6
would mean king c5 and we win
just that easy
isn't king c2 also linked with f8 so no
let's step back to our initial position
here and
ignore those squares focus on the main
square here
so these eight squares are all unique
remember i could only draw them in four
colors because that's all the colors i
have
but these are all unique it's an eight
square system so there are eight unique
squares
one two three and then four five six
seven
eight all eight unique squares so
none of these squares correspond to any
other squares
in this eight square system uh
okay so what does that mean that means
this square only corresponds
to this one this square only corresponds
to this one
yellow only to yellow this one only here
right there's no other
squares that they correspond to in this
eight square system now
this extends outwards past the eight
squares but in those eight squares those
are the only things
okay does that make sense
does that make sense
feels like 4d geometry it's very
beautiful stuff right very beautiful
stuff
so okay once again
we started with our shortest path for
both sides
between the key squares of g4 and d6
right the shortest path between those
two for both sides
from there we noticed this triangle
pattern this is the first pattern we
should look for
where we construct an eight square
system okay
that's step number two we found this
linking square
then we decided to say that these
eight squares are linked as such
and then we realized we can extend the
pattern out in this manner
sorry this extends here this extends
here
right and we can extend it all the way
to the edge of the board and that's how
we discovered
king a2 is the winning move
what does it mean that the squares are
linked
at its basic level are you not just
shrinking the board
maybe i don't know i don't think so but
maybe
um so what does it mean that they're
linked so in its most basic form let's
show these the shortest path again these
are our first corresponding squares that
are very easy to determine because
they're the shortest path
between the key squares corresponding
and linked mean the same thing
so if white steps to f4 black must step
to f5
right if white steps to e3 black must
step to g6
if white steps to d4 black must step to
f7 otherwise black loses the game
and so we built these linked squares
outwards until we discovered
which square can we step to where black
can't step
to a linked square and that square would
allow us a path to victory no matter
what black does
okay
isn't the shortest path enough to
remember how to play this so yeah that's
what the idea is the idea is what we
learn tonight
is going to allow us to solve any
position
by just finding the shortest path so
this is just one
of the many patterns okay one of the
many patterns
is this triangle system here but
sometimes
we'll see you can't always form the
triangle system
so let's move on to another example now
and hopefully things will start getting
a little bit more clear
all right here we have a very very very
similar position
g4 is still a key square d6 is still a
key square
what's the shortest path between them
i'm just going to tell you guys
it's this to here to here to here
right everybody sees this is the
shortest path to get between the
two key squares and black's path is
going to be the same as last time as
well
all right what is the difference
well the difference is we put a pawn on
f2
and a pawn on f3 so what that
means is that we cannot quite
form our eight square system why is that
well it's because one of our squares
in our eight square system is defended
and that just blows the whole thing up
all right just blows it right up no
longer works
we're busted can't do it anymore we just
can't do it anymore i'm sorry we can't i
know you'll want to
but we can't do it so what can we do
well now we can go to what i think is
probably the most common system that is
formed by the shortest path the most
common pattern
which is called the quadratic system
in comprehensive chess endings and i
think it's a good enough good enough
name so how can you form
the quadratic system well there are two
patterns
you can form it from okay this is
pattern number one
and pattern number one is when you have
this
triangle system together but you can't
use
all eight squares so all that's required
for this pattern to work is that you
have
the ability to make a two by two square
behind one base of the triangle does
that make sense
a two by two square behind one base of
the triangle so here's our triangle
right we have a base down here but we
cannot form a two by two square
because this base or this this square
is uh defended but on this other base of
the triangle we very much can form
a two by two square okay and this two by
two square
is the basis of our entire pattern for
this system the quadratic system the two
by two pattern
so once again we can use this pattern
because we have these two two squares
which are diagonally connected
and are linked by this one square in the
middle and then
one of the bases of this triangle has
these two spaces behind
it so we can form a two by two square
behind
one base of the triangle we would not be
able to do this
in the previous puzzle because we could
make the more strict
eight square system
of this cannot do it here because the
square is defended
so we fall back on this quadratic system
does that make sense
steve i will show something like that in
this puzzle i don't want to jump back
and forth too much but that that is a
good question
why g4 not f4 how do you decide so it's
the same key squares as the last puzzle
uh which when we were deciding those key
squares i said f4
appears to be a key square but to be a
true key square
it has to be a square where you are
completely winning
uh regardless of where you put the enemy
king within reason
obviously regardless of where you put
the enemy king on any reasonable square
it could get to
so on f4 if the enemy king is on h5 you
don't win
because your king would have to retreat
however if your king is on g4
doesn't matter where you put the enemy
king you're gonna win you take f3 next
you push your g
pawn easy one
it supersedes it king lore pirate you
have to use the eight square system
if possible otherwise this stuff doesn't
work
you'll get messed up uh okay so
in this case though eight square system
failed us
garbage doesn't work so two by two
system which is like i said
slightly i think significantly more
common so let's build it
how does it work well let's get rid of
these extraneous squares
and focus on the key squares not sorry
not the key squares the important
squares
to our pattern which are d4 e3
and g6f7 these corresponding squares
right
this is how we'll make the pattern for
both sides here
uh so like i said the important thing to
start with is this
linking square between the two and i
keep using
difficult terms this square between the
two that connects to both of them
and so that of course will correspond to
g7 as well
and now we have these two squares that
form the rest
of our what's called the main zone in
comprehensive chess endings that's their
term for it
the main part of our pattern from which
we can extend out
and it's these two squares that are left
so we have
c4 and c3 and now depending on the
position
sometimes these squares are distinct and
sometimes they are not
sometimes they serve the same function
so of course for black
we're on the side closer to d6 so black
must also be on the side closer to d6
this side of course closer to the g4
which would correspond to this side
or on this side closer to d6
for black those are these squares and
believe it or not
we can even get rid of those those two
from these four keys
from these four corresponding squares
you can build out the rest of the
pattern
it's just that easy with the quadratic
system
you have a two by two little set up here
and then from that
it's the rest of the pattern is obvious
and it actually extends the exact same
way as the eight square
system d4 extends out to d2
d3 to d1 so on and so forth
and this time i actually do have enough
colors
so the colors i'm putting here actually
mean all these squares
are essentially identical okay
so all those squares just extend out and
it's as easy as that
so chat room what's the correct answer
here with this knowledge
what's the correct answer from which
book yes comprehensive chess endings
the series with uh that averbach is the
author for most of it but the chapter on
uh corresponding squares i believe was
actually written
by michael zarin
so yeah of course it's king b2 because
h7
is the extension of f7 and so we go king
b2
right we go king b2
and now my question is what if he steps
to g7
can you guys figure out the
corresponding square
to g7 without the circles on the board
and i'll just remind you briefly we have
these four squares for white
and these four squares for black these
are the important ones
these four squares for white these four
squares for black
can you figure it out this has a lot to
do with distant opposition i think
that's sort of getting it backwards uh
kerenth
i think distant opposition has its roots
in corresponding squares
rather than the other way around uh i
think the best way i've heard it phrased
is that
uh positions where there's distant
opposition is sort of a a specific
instance
of corresponding squares sort of linking
together
so yeah of course it is king b3 how do
we know that
well let's highlight our four squares
here and i'm no longer going to use
colors as a shortcut
we have d4 which of course corresponds
to f7
d3 g7 c3
g8 c4 f8
and so he stepped to g7 corresponding to
d3 we extend d3 out this way
and king b3 is the direct answer
king b8 now or sorry king g8 is likely
the best try i take it back king f7 is
likely the most confusing try
now for white we have these four squares
king f7 corresponds to king d4
so where should white step of course he
should step to the extension of d4
on b4 now let's say
king back to g8s this is stepping too
far away now
from the shortest path when white would
win
so if king f8 keeping an eye on e7
now of course the corresponding square
to f8 d4 f7
c4 f8 we step here king f7
king d4 and once again
we find ourselves on the shortest path
and
black has to make a move we just inched
our way towards the shortest path
always stepping to the corresponding
squares and now black
is once again in zugzwang choosing
either between
the left side of the board in the d6
pawn the d6 square
or the right side of the board in the g4
square let's say king g6
we go this way winning the game
say king g7 same issue king f8 now we go
this way
winning the game okay
uh as far as the question of
i i think this was somebody's question
in the chat about the last
the last puzzle what happens if black
just sort of makes a b line for the
shortest path how does he ever lose this
game
well the fact is now that you're on the
shortest path
if you start choosing between squares
white is able to get to
to one of the key squares right he's
white is keeping his options open
between which square on the shortest
path he picks and he can
sort of uh juke you out right you go one
way he goes the other
and so hopefully that's a little bit
more apparent here
any questions any questions on this one
didn't i say c2 wins instead of b4 or is
it different in that case
so let's play a move so king b3 king g7
so here we have our four squares and our
four squares
uh g7 corresponds to d2
and okay no sorry
i did this backwards so king b2 king g7
yeah king b3 so why doesn't king c2 win
here
well because it extends out uh
orthogonally
knots not diagonally like this
so these four squares are our distinct
squares in this case and extending it
out it's actually c4
that is connected to c2 not b not d3
so c4 corresponds to f8 so that means
that after king c2 black can step to f8
and he's on the corresponding square and
now all of a sudden the position is
drawn
no way to break through
for white we get boxed
see we're on the shortest path but now
it's our turn to move
and it will always be our turn to move
now because black can maneuver
on the corresponding squares
is the draw if you go to the wrong
square that's correct that's correct
if it was black to move first what would
be the outcome
that's a good question let's get the
position with black to move
black to move here and actually it is
black to move
and draw so how can we figure that out
we have our four squares we have our
extension of the pattern
c4 goes to c2 c2 a2
or like this so black merely needs to
step to the corresponding square
on his half of the board in this case f8
corresponds to c4
and so king h8 draws the game
believe it or not okay so
that's what we have here that's this
study
hopefully you guys have a good grasp on
that if not hopefully or giving it a
re-watch
will allow you to fully understand it so
now in this example
all four of these squares were distinct
corresponding squares and then we
extended the pattern out
but it does turn out that is not always
uh the case
and when that is not the case
is when you have the very interesting
case of uh
these two squares being equidistant from
the shortest path
in all cases in this case they're not
equidistant
c4 is one step away from c5 whereas
c3 is two steps away from c5 so
you see they are unique squares here
uh and we're gonna do one more where
they are unique squares and then
hopefully we'll get to one
where they are not so let's do one more
this is an end game study as well
and i'm going to skip sort of that first
part
so i'm going to go through this first
part pretty quickly we need
the key squares what are the key squares
well it turns out
if white gets to f6 or g6 he absolutely
always wins the game
if he gets to b6 or c6
he also always wins the game as well as
a6 so we have our key squares here
so what's our shortest path between the
key squares
well we have this square for white
these two are actually identical because
they can both step to c3
and here right and now a5
and g5 are actually also
going to be unique squares here
the reason being g5 threatens to step
to closer to the queen side as well as
to these squares okay so this is our
shortest path
for whites black's shortest path is a
little bit easier
to see
okay this is black's shortest path so we
have one
two three four five six steps
and we have one two three
four five six steps sorry a7
is also important uh the reason being
uh if white steps to a5 black is
not good enough on b7 because from b7
white could go king b5 and then invade a
key square
so this is what we have here right this
is our shortest path for both sides
and now you notice the pretty distinct
difference from last time
is we have this ambiguity here we have
these ambiguous squares
in the center and so hate these squares
hate when there's ambiguity why is there
ambiguity well because
white could black could step to e8 and
then back to d7 and then back to c8 and
still get to b7
in the same number of steps as if he
just went directly across the seventh
rank
so it turns out these squares are
ambiguous doesn't matter where black
steps as long as he's stepping on one of
them
so to form a pattern we cannot use
those slightly ambiguous squares which
means
we're not happy with these central
squares for forming patterns we don't
like them
we just don't like it okay what we do
see
is on the end we have two adjacent
squares
and this is in fact sort of a shortcut
from the
base of the triangle that we found in
the last study
so once again i'm going to jump back
really quickly in the last study
we formed our triangle from
this base sorry we formed our two by two
square
from the base of this triangle which had
space behind it
so now rather than a triangle we just
use these two adjacent squares
for either side okay
and then works exactly the same we build
our four out behind it
and those are our four squares okay
so now i'm going to ask you guys at home
using these four squares can you extend
the pattern in your head
to find white to move and win this
position
why f8 why not f8 for black
because sorry on the shortest path if
white is on f5 it's not enough for black
to be
on f8 he needs to be on f7 does that
make sense
blacks on f8 and white can invade
because it's touching the key squares
yeah everybody's already got it king g1
now hard mode here king f7
white to move and win white to move and
win
you don't even get those initial four
squares now you got to remember them all
king g1 was great king ju1 was great
so this is the tough one now this is the
tough one
and yeah you guys have the right idea of
course
not king g2 because from our pattern
we know that king g2 corresponds to king
g8
when we have a drawn position but rather
king f1 is winning the game
and now the really tricky bits king e7
white to move and win
this is sort of the the final hard move
to find
well the corresponding squares here
chess king after king e7 become very
important
chess king says king e1
we have oh yes so it turns out this is
the difficult move to find
so king e1 king g2 king e1 king e2 king
e1 king e2
and yeah it turns out not king
e2 king e2
could of course be mets by let's figure
it out
we have our squares here uh which square
is e2
e2 corresponds to g4 which corresponds
to g8
g8 extends out to e8 king e8
drawn position but king
g2 and
now it turns out
even though king e8 would be stepping to
the quote-unquote corresponding square
here
the difference now is that at the end of
the day
stepping of course
to these squares king g4
king g8 black cannot actually ever make
it back
over to the g file and after king g5
king f7 king f5 white wins the game
so
the correct answer is king g1 king f7
king f1 king e7 king g2
when black cannot step to the
corresponding square
on g8 okay
and then if black steps back to f8
white to move and win of course we don't
step up we step to f2
staying on the corresponding square
right uh king back to e7
now we can step up king f7 king f3
and
sorry not king there king let's say king
f8 we would have to go king f4
and we win the game right uh and now
the hard part of this puzzle is
realizing
that we are actually in time to stop
black
from going this way and
what happens if
black tries to step over to the
king side well now we can actually
go this way and black is is busted
so we started with these four
corresponding squares and
we extend them all the way down the
board and that's how we find king g1
king f1
king g2 which is very mysterious to the
naked eye
but makes a lot of sense when you figure
out this
system of corresponding squares
okay does q1 there draw
let's find out king e1
i believe should draw
this one is going to be a lot less
intuitive i think king e8
is the drawing move and the point now is
if you step to e2
king e7 uh and the reason
for all of this is ah yes the reason is
these two squares were identical on
black's shortest path
he can get to any of the important
squares he needs to get to
from either of those squares so once
again
distant opposition not enough to tell
you the answer there
uh it's not intuitive that e8 and e7 are
the same square for black
and in all useful sense of the word e7
and e8
are the same square so king e8 and if
you start coming this way
king f8 is the corresponding square
come up the board not going to be enough
not going to be enough even king f8 here
okay let's do one more
really really quick and we'll figure it
out here
so i mentioned this a little bit earlier
on
about
sometimes the two
rear squares behind the uh
behind the squares on the shortest path
are sometimes counted as the same
when their distance to the shortest path
is identical when they are equidistant
so let's really quickly work this one
out here
we have once again our shortest path on
the board
for both sides because d5 and h6
are sorry and h6 g6 are all key squares
okay just trust me on that one we didn't
have time to for me to ask you guys
on that one this is sort of our key
squares and our shortest path
uh and so from here where can we
build um our glorious
uh base well we can do it
here right we can build our little
two by two section notably we cannot use
the eight square method because this
square
is defended by black so we go back to
the quadratic method
and the quadratic method tells us that
these four squares
are important right for black it's this
square
and these squares those are the
corresponding squares
now why are the two squares not unique
here well like i said
it's because their distance to the
shortest path is equal
they are equidistant what does that mean
that means it takes
two turns to get to g4 from f2
but it also takes two turns to get to g4
from e2
similarly it just takes one turn to get
to f3 from either square
and so it takes two turns to get to e4
from either score as well meaning they
are equidistant to the shortest path
on both sides and because of that
they are only counted
as sort of a unit
they correspond to the same squares and
they're sort of entertain
interchangeable uh so what does that
mean
for our pattern well it means
that this is also going to be
one of those squares because it
threatens to step to those two
and so that means that black is also
sort of stuck in this position here
so of course the winning move here is
king d2
when black is now split between covering
the corresponding square
to e3 which is of course d7
and from covering um
the key this square on the shortest path
and from covering this square which
allows white
to choose between the three right
so if black could move super far he
would put this king
on d8 and easily draw the game here
but he can't move the king super far so
he has to choose one
king d7 is the best try
when let's figure this out now these are
our four
squares where can we step to to win the
game now
well we want to force black to choose
between one of these two so we can step
to the other one so king d3 is the
answer
now if king c6 you get met with not king
e4
sorry but of course
these four squares the one that black
abandoned
was king e2 so this wins the game
now king back we can step king f3
if king over we can step king e3
e3 corresponding to d7
now king here white goes here
and finally black has to choose between
between the shortest paths if that makes
sense
sorry i super rushed through that last
one to show an example
of where the
back two squares of the two by two uh
quadratic square that we make were sort
of treated as the same
so that one might have not made the most
sense as i went through it pretty
quickly
but hopefully you guys are starting to
get a feel
for these corresponding square positions
i think i'll probably do a follow-up
lecture
to go over number one this idea in more
detail and number two
a couple more of the potential type of
scenarios
that you can get almost all of them
are based on either this eight square
system or this quadratic system
or a third one which is called the
triangle
system or some combination
of those three and really that triangle
system
is very very rare so we'll talk a little
bit more about this next week but
hopefully you guys
have a really good start now on this
sort of
geometrical way of creating
corresponding squares in positions i
know it's
really complex stuff and it's not a lot
of
you know just general chess ideas but it
is a lot of
sort of this almost math problem like
feeling to him
uh i hope you guys enjoyed that is it
for us here on the youtube channel
tonight we will be doing
analyze your games live on twitch
directly after this so
be sure to check it out other than that
my name is caleb denby thank you so much
for watching and i will see you next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
time
you